أصبح مصنع الأسفلت المهجور بالقرب من
كييف الآن ساحة تدريب للمدنيين
الذين تطوعوا لمحاربة غزو روسي محتمل ،
حيث يفوقهم عدد هنا عدد الصحفيين
والمسلحين في أحسن الأحوال ببنادق الحبيبات التي
يعلمون أنها ستفوقهم
آلة موسكو العسكرية ،
لكنهم كذلك  حرصًا
منا على أن يكون لدينا لحظة حاسمة بالنسبة لبلدنا ،
فلدينا حقًا
مخاطرة كبيرة بأن الغزو الروسي
قد يحدث
قريبًا ، ولهذا السبب
يجب على المدنيين أن يكونوا مستعدين
يعتقد هؤلاء الرجال أن
ديمقراطية بلادهم هي ما يخشى فلاديمير بوتين
أكثر من التهديد الذي يمثله
الاتحاد الأوروبي أو  عضوية الناتو
في روسيا بوتين ،
جميع المواطنين الروس هم عبيد تمامًا
، يشعر بالتهديد لأن الأوكرانيين
أعطوا الروس وما دون الروس
مثالًا سيئًا
يجب أن نظهر لجيراننا كيف يجب على
كل
مواطن يتمتع بالإرادة الحرة
أن
يدافع عن
حقوقه الاجتماعية
والوطنية.  لا أعلم أن
الحكومة الأوكرانية تقول أن روسيا لديها ما لا يقل عن
127000 جندي محتشدون في ثلاثة جوانب
من  بلد هنا في العاصمة حيث
لا توجد علامات على حرب وشيكة
وفي المناطق الأكثر فقرًا حيث
يبذل الناس كل ما في وسعهم للحصول على
الحالة المزاجية ، يشعر
الأشخاص المماثلون بالراحة على الرغم من
أنني أقول للبعض لا يعتمد ذلك على الدوائر
التي تتواصل معها
إذا كان شخص ما  في عائلتك من
الجيش أو الشرطة ، إنه اسم مختلف تمامًا
ولكن يتم فتح ملاجئ الغارات الجوية القديمة
فقط في حالة قيام
الحكومة الأوكرانية بمناشدة
سكانها من أجل الهدوء ولكن في نفس الوقت
نفض الغبار عن هذه المخابئ التي تعود إلى الحقبة السوفيتية
نظرًا لوجودها  يمثل تهديدًا للديمقراطية في دولة شابة ،
يمكن لهذا الملجأ أن يأوي حوالي 300 شخص
، حتى أنه يحتوي على نظام تنقية الهواء يدويًا.
المفارقة أن
لا أحد هنا هو أن هذا الملجأ تم
بناؤه في عام 1956 للحماية من هجوم الناتو على
روسيا والاتحاد السوفيتي
الآن يوفر مأوى ضد
هجوم ssible من قبل روسيا
سام كيلي سي إن كييف